ah next one
this looks like my kids have this like
30 mp3 player with a camera on it that's
what that looks like hey guys it's vadim
angelica and max and in this video we're
doing an unbiased camera comparison with
the brand new z flip 4 the iphone 13 and
the pixel 6a and i'm super excited
because vadim went out he took a bunch
of photos he edited them together and we
have not seen them yet under this first
image so we are going to be voting which
image looks the best uh and you guys
go ahead and get a piece of paper in the
pen uh play along with us take down your
score let us know what you get in the
comments all right so i'm gonna be super
opinionated because i usually don't get
to do this and usually it's me getting
to get in the photo so
just kidding i'm gonna go with the left
one me too because
the ground is not that dark that is
crazy dark that is blue the colors look
great that's the image i wanted my phone
there's so much detail on the left one
and looking at the water i see a lot of
like bright shadows like it's so
three-dimensional where i don't see that
in the center let's see what we get
z-flip yeah whoa
looks good all right and the next one
this i believe is ultra wide man that
center one looks so
flat and clumpy it's also just too
bright i gotta go for the left one i
like the highlights and the clouds some
of the contrast here i definitely see a
lot more detail on the left than in both
of those all right pixel
all right now for the next one we have
just a regular main camera shot for
detail to me this one looks too flat
that one looks too dark this one i like
the colors and the detail looks nice
okay oh yeah the detail
along this trunk and everything looks
really nice definitely a lot
less this is sucky one second whatever
that is let's see what it is
iphone 13 did better pretty good um that
looks good we have a selfie
okay this is not portrait man this is so
great this is in the morning you're
completely gray but even gray in the
morning
i really like the colors on the right
one it looks the most natural but
everything in the back is so gray so
flat you kind of blend in with the
background right yeah i keep changing my
mind but i think i'm gonna go with the
center one i would just make it warmer i
agree
whoa so the flip was the warm one all
right now we have a portrait shot this
looks like the first time that iphone's
got portrait mode
where it's just messed up and then crazy
right there
that's really really intense
i think i like the light i like the left
one the best what is it
okay
that's interesting in our last camera
comparison we did the fold in the s22
ultra the iphone was getting destroyed
at first all right this is a close-up
basically like macro detail they all
look good very close i just think the
center has the most detail
all right let's see what it is it is the
another iphone iphone 13. all right the
next one this is my boy jacka on his
nice four-wheeler four-wheeler
look at all that glow i know he's
staring on him that's beautiful this one
is a horse
it looks like
it's over sharp like it's like a fake
detail it made him look old what is
happening
is benjamin button
he's only two years old yeah the colors
are nice the details i mean that's
beautiful this one looks pretty good too
good but this he's popular more
sharpness is good that is by far the
worst one so center
that looks beautiful beautiful pixel
what went rough oh
oh yep oh the pixel's still doing that
annoying thing where it forces you to
crop in is using half the sensor and it
looks bad it looks bad all right this
next one nice little
sunrise with a boat
that center one i do like the center one
where you have more of the highlights
kept instead of blowing out some of the
colors i don't like that flaring yeah
but i was supposed to make the center
yeah definitely center center yep
wow pretty good i'm very surprised that
the dynamic range is so good on the
z-flip the z-flip 3 had sucky cameras
all right so this is a basically zoomed
in shot because neither of these have
telephoto cameras this is like what yeah
the big four people try to take bigfoot
photos and you can't see nothing because
they're zeus um i think i'm gonna go
with the last i think so too even though
the detail still kind of sucks but i
like the colors there okay let's see
so that's the original right there okay
so the interesting thing is the iphone
only goes up to 5x yep pixel goes 7x z
flip goes 10x right out of the camera so
10x and it looks better i guess that's
why the iphone stops you because it's
going to look terrible if you zoom in
that much all right the next one this is
eli and then
jumped in
nice little portrait shot so i think i
have to go for the center even though
eugene is not in it which sucks
uh i like the colors it looks natural
the blur looks good did you guys notice
this right here
no
oh i did like back here
yeah it looks like it's in here look at
this super blurry and then a hard that's
true a hard cut to like super in focus
that center one is like perfect what is
it
what the heck all right the next one
this is a portrait against the sun so
it's very difficult obviously a lot of
flaring i think i'm gonna go with the
center they all suck
i would have turned around
i know we test this because situations
like this come up you want to get the
sunset i think i have to go center even
though uh there's some more small flares
here which kind of distracting compared
to one huge one here but it's still
detailed and it still looks good iphone
13 13. interesting now this one i set
all of them to 5x because the iphone
only goes to maximum five so they're all
even i am seeing a ton more detail on
the right yeah this one actually looks
like it has a telephoto camera which
none of these have telephoto cameras
that one looks good but this one looks
somewhat decent this looks bad no that
looks so all the detail last this one
looks terrible
[Music]
why does the iphone look so bad all
right next one portrait
okay center wow definitely the center
this is so flat completely centered yeah
this was also against the sun which
makes it a tough tough situation so both
use center definitely i think so that
one's not bad too the the colors are
nice on the face i like that okay so
pixel 6
which you can see here actually cropped
in to make them all even but what about
that does that look kind of weird that's
kind of annoying but okay but it is
really clean all right next
left
one
left instantly yep that's really nice
and sharp you could actually like read
it where these fail what is that
so i actually made them even so pixel
once again for zoom shots wow pixel
pixels yeah yeah it's starting to catch
up okay oh okay this is a portrait not
the center i just don't like how
everything is just so wide up there
there's like no detail yeah true these
look more real life oh man that level
looks so bad what's going on i think we
already know which one that is at this
point like each of these portrait shots
with people
just don't look great definitely right
yeah right definitely right it looks
natural looks really nice i'm very
surprised you guys chose right because
that was actually a crap
because i went from further away this
was the only one that could take it that
far away i think does this one allow you
to do a portrait shot and like to choose
to be closer like this one forces you to
be closer yeah but the iphone doesn't
let you have that option i don't know
but i was able to be further away here
with the iphone and i'm surprised you
guys chilling it still looks better it
still looks good okay this is just a
regular main he's posing this is tough
angelica you should you should say your
opinion i might need some pointers on
this one i think i'm going to go with
the center it looks really natural i
don't see as much detail
on the left one
or the right one like in his face the
second one looks really good to me i
would be happy with any of these photos
in my
phone oh good they're all great i think
got to go at the center too okay
that's the iphone
okay this is a close-up shot well i like
the colors the best in the center i see
a lot more detail in the center these
ones look kind of like almost blurry to
me
yeah i guess here it focused on the back
one but not the main one
you see yeah a little bit here there um
this one looks the worst by far yeah so
much detail look at all that what yeah
yeah so go with the center stuff the
fuel yep z-flip flip that's the z-power
brought out that color oh okay so we got
a doorway with
bright sky in the back wow these two are
so blown out over there
that one looks really balanced you're
right we do have a lot more detail in
the back we don't have all that blown
out and then all these rays also the
highlights pop more you have the nice
colors the ambience looks really nice
that's not blown out definitely the
center one both center pixel separation
that is surprising okay
yeah this is a portrait
the left one's so bad very bad terrible
look at all this blur not only do you
have way too much blur here but this
whole corner is messed up and all of
this is just so messy too it's not clean
at all yeah this looks like it's just
like i said before like original iphone
portrait mode i think i like the center
one more the background's a little more
blurry which i like because you want to
focus on this
yeah it's tough but i'll go for the
center too center again
it's the idea iphone okay these are
not cropping not forcing you to crop but
when you crop it still looks better than
this first yeah okay
it's a lot of zoom in this one all right
let's find the pixel out of these old
guys
man that left one the left one is
garbage
that one is bad this one is so like
blurry everywhere in the text and down
oh yeah this one's really sharp noise
reduction in this definitely the one on
the right oh yeah one on the right okay
oh yeah
pixel 6a again it's so good at some
stuff and so bad at other stuff i wonder
how this got all this artifacting
another portrait this is inside so it's
not as bright it's tough mixed light
kind of lower yeah man that center one
looks really bad
just on their face as everything is so
dark true but this one also looks too
warm to me
it does look too warm
this is i i don't know i don't like this
one because of sharpening
and colors i would probably just take
this and bring up the exposure a little
bit in the phone
but i would still choose the center i
think i'm going to go with the left one
actually to me the center one looks the
most like over sharpened interesting
let's see
iphone x
pixel and not the z flip it's very warm
for some reason yeah
okay it's hanging regular shots hanging
by the nieces yep this is a regular i am
seeing a lot more detail in the center
the one on the right there's barely any
detail his face everything looks
smushed and like in his clothes the
pants there's so much more detail on the
center one center
center
i was gonna say kind of looks like um
what's that mode that the iphone has
where it stacks images for detail in
like middle lighting situations yeah
we forgot what it's called but if it's
if that's defusion diffusion if that's
what it's doing it's doing it it's
pretty good
ah
baby on the grass
this is already dark it's already uh sun
past sunset at this point this is so
bright it looks like you're right in the
sun
you could just bring it down a little
bit but that right one looks really bad
everything looks fake and on this one
grass everything yeah and his face looks
like all one tone and this is somewhat
kind of like that too this looks more
let's uh i'll i'll go with the left i'll
go i think it's the best in the world
pixel 6
left nice the iphone is so bad what yeah
super flat next one hey i got a picture
of myself nice
dollar tree
looks most natural colors look great
detail looks great everything
iphone iphone got a sign
young a church families this is portrait
or regular this is regular i'm gonna go
with the center i see a lot of detail
everything looks natural the colors this
one looks a little i don't know
something about it looks really fake
that really like stands out and is
really clean yeah to me this looks more
most like a dslr shot i also noticed
detail in those highlights not only the
color but there's like a little bit of
clouds where this is kind of um just
worn out good point 13 again iphone 13.
doing really well okay oh
wow
that was so dark this one's super dark
this one has all this artifacting and
crazy ugliness right there
that one looks the most clean
again
what happens with the iphone yes and the
pad usually doesn't happen and oh okay
so we got a dark interior shot lots of
glowing lights this is very tough to
shoot this yeah that right one is nice i
think i zoomed into 2x on each of them i
have to go with the center yeah i agree
this is not far off that one's a lot
it's really bad
pixel success pixel nice zoom shots
that's great z-flip you didn't do great
there you go oh okay this is dark in the
church so it's kind of like a darker
selfie that looks like it is in good
lighting
that's right it looks like it's in good
lighting
not bad there colors brightness this is
sad this one is terrible yep oh i know
why because
it has the
interior camera which i think is 10
megapixels i think it is yeah and it's
definitely not as good so that's that
one
yeah that is the seat
i just yeah i remember it i guess yeah
okay okay next all right we're getting
into the dark like this is pitch black
already we drove to camp man that's so
much contrast yeah and i'm not sure if i
like it i do kind of but yeah the center
one looks really flat to me
the left one looks pretty good yeah i
don't like that it's cool like i feel
like it's too cool it is only blue but
that one is so dark that one's too dark
too dark yeah but i'm gonna go with the
right one i'm gonna go with the left
okay pixel and iphone z flip did not win
i think it's maybe a little flat right
all right and the next one
together
oh wait i think man right the one on the
yeah the one on the right definitely by
far and i this phone sucks that is clean
huh look at that you got the glowing
lights yeah really good the skin and why
is the background all great like it
looks like a filter what is that almost
like it tried to turn the lights white
yes you are right and then this one's
still a little too blue
that one's very good it looks like a
dslr shot
flip oh gosh and pixel fans oh i'm sorry
i'm sorry
okay so
this is when we're bringing up the
exposure a little bit
dude
look at that jumbled mess of artifacts
that's true i was gonna say i like how
the car looks but
yeah i mean that looks pretty good that
looks pretty good you can even see the
stars yeah they're start okay i think i
might know which one it is but
regardless the middle one yep
i thought
wow what did you think i thought it was
the pixel because it does great at night
mode shots i was going to say it
redeemed itself after the last shot but
iphone wow
so this is handheld handheld trying to
do uh night mode on each one okay center
one
multiple seconds it's exposing i would
be so sad if i had this this looks like
my kids have this like 30 mp3 player
with a camera on it that's what that
looks like this is beautiful
i'm surprised you got that with handheld
yeah it's pretty good buy far better
it's the iphone no way yeah so that's 10
seconds and these two i think did like
four or five seconds or something each
wow that is beautiful
all right this is basically the same
thing handheld again so i mean i guess
how often do you have a tripod yeah like
who's gonna carry on a tripod unless
you're like a pro unless you go camping
you want to take star photos like i mean
center
yeah i i'm not gonna say anything yeah
center one
yeah the iphone so is there no way to
make these go longer unless you put them
on a tripod yep the only way is tripod
as far as i know at least for the pixel
all right so nice cam setup
a lot of differences in white balance a
swap
oh because of that color spill
everywhere that is a swan there's a lot
of colors this is so blue i don't think
your lights are
like daylight lights they're actually
kind of like white like with the cool i
mean it actually i won't say what it
looked like because that looks pretty
that looks great this is the photo i'd
one in my in my phone this that one here
yeah yep it's actually the colors were
like this it's like a more white not
blue okay z flip wow wow what did the
iphone do i'm used to the pixel not
doing crazy yeah the iphone did not do
this all right and i think this is the
last one right here
wow
beautiful what does better look at those
stars
i kind of like how this has a little bit
more highlights but then i guess it
takes away from the sky anyways this is
what you want to look at color
yeah wow and this
i don't know what phone this was but
it's sad
yeah
all right
there you go we actually have the amount
of times on here too the pixel lets you
do for me i actually put it down on the
tripod and it was actually kind of
annoying because i'm sitting there
waiting for four minutes i'm like dude i
want to go already you know how i feel
every comparison it's so slow 30 seconds
is actually pretty good and the z flip i
went through the whole like front screen
menu trying to figure out like how do i
increase the time i don't know
couldn't figure it out i was trying to
tap yeah in 50 seconds you got a couple
stars but they look like more like dust
on the lens
yeah all right that was it 35 photos
total so if you went along with us
comment down below what you got for each
phone and who's going first
i want to go first i can go first i will
say this was very fun um the pixel does
great at certain things but overall it's
yeah it's either really good or really
bad the flip some shots that was good
colors it's really good the iphone i
think is the most well-rounded
surprisingly
um so i have
nine for the pixel
10 for the z flip one better and 16 for
the iphone and i have nine for the flip
10 for the pixel and also 16
69 so very similar even though we
voted against each other on some of
those
uh but at the end that is the result now
if you guys think that we're iphone
fanboys and this is rigged go see watch
the other bold comparison against iphone
13 pro yeah and that's 22 ultra
different surprises this is surprising
results because the flip is the most
expensive right out of all of them it is
a thousand dollars
and it didn't do that well it didn't
yeah i guess it depends on how much
money is in that whole hinge and that
screen and it's the second screen and
all that stuff so thank you guys for
watching
go ahead and hit that circle above to
subscribe check out one of those great
videos right over there and we will see
you in the next one
[Music]